MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
My name's Moonlit.
I'm a partner developer
manager at Google Play.
I specialize in games.
I've been with Google
for three years.
Before Google, I was a
revenue PM at a mobile gaming
company called Scopely.
At the time, and also
for the three years
I've been working
with Google, one
of the most common
questions is, how do we
monetize in the world
of games as a service?
But before I jump in, I want
to understand you guys better.
Show of hands, how many of
you have premium games only?
Oh, surprising.
How many of you have IP
games and not purchase games?
Great.
Awesome.
So here's the deal.
I'm not going to say that
everything I'll tell you today
is new.
But my takeaway, my hope for
you to take away from my talk,
is to think about
revenue diversification.
Think about different
ways to monetize.
Think about different ways to
design your game to monetize.
So I'll talk about three
different things in the next 30
minutes.
First is about LTV--
what it is and why
it's important.
Second, I'll share a list of
common in-game monetization
designs for game as a
service, free-to-play games
with in-app purchases.
And last, I'll
end with some tips
about earning in
the global market,
because as you launch your
game with Google Play,
it is by default
a global business.
All right, first, LTV.
LTV, or Life Time Value.
Remember the last time you
walked into a video game store.
Can somebody tell
me what is the LTV
of a customer in the traditional
world of console PC gaming?
AUDIENCE: Is that with one game?
MOONLIT: One game,
just one game.
What's the LTV of one game?
Any guesses?
What's the lifetime value of
a customer if you buy a game?
AUDIENCE: The price.
MOONLIT: It's just
a price of the game.
In this old world, simple.
You make a game.
You sell it.
Transaction is done.
You make some money,
and you move on.
But in the world of
games as a service,
it's a little bit more complex.
Your game now, your
revenue now is the sum
of many micro transactions.
Therefore, your
players' lifetime value
is now heavily affected by two
things, lifetime value, time
and value.
What is time?
Time is engagement.
So we're going to look
into both of these very
important elements of LTV.
I'm not going to dive
into how to calculate it.
It's a whole different science.
But what we're going to talk
about is very high level.
How do you increase LTV by
increasing and understanding
engagement and the value?
For engagement, the question
is, how do we track engagement?
What does it mean?
At Google Play, we look
at two buckets of things.
The first one is hard retention.
What are the percentage of
users who come back to your game
the next day, a month
later, a week later?
And I'll share with you what
are some benchmarks by category.
The second one is
engagement profile.
First is frequency-- session
frequency and session time,
which measures how much time
a player spends in your game
and how often they play.
The second one we call
the stickiness factor.
It's a pretty common
standardized industry term,
which is DAU divided
by MAU, or how likely
you are to convert a very
infrequent player into a more
committed one.
So of the three,
retention is king.
More so, long-term retention
is what we really care about.
So on the right-hand side, you
can see by broad stroke the day
30 retention number of core,
mid-core, very, very broad
stroke, high level
different genres.
Most of the games we see fall
in the grassy green area.
You want to aspire to be in
the forest green, on top.
Let's imagine that we care
about long-term retention,
because the more
time a player spend
in your game, that's more
opportunities for you
to monetize.
And the more time
they spend in the game
also signals that
they are committed
to you and to your game.
So these fans are also
more likely to pay higher,
to pay more.
On the graph on the
right-hand side,
we plotted the top grossing
games on Google Play.
This is retention over time
grouped by top 10 grossing,
top 100, top 1,000.
As you can see, good retention
is strictly correlated
with revenue potential as well.
So my recommendation for
you is to really think
about how to design your game to
create a long-term experience.
Think about when people
churn, why do they churn?
How do you prevent churn?
And remember more
engagement, more time spent,
means more LTV.
Now, let's talk about the
second element of LTV, the value
element.
We look at churn for
a lot of the players,
and found that the churn between
a person who never spends
and the person who spends
the very first dollar
drops off immediately.
And it plateaus after that.
What this shows me is that
the most important dollar
a player can spend your game
is the very first one, which
is unfortunately also the most
difficult hurdle to overcome.
But some of the mechanics
I'll show you later
will address this.
I think David also
mentioned this.
Past spending is also
the best predictor
of future spending patterns.
Again, it reaffirms
why that first dollar
is very, very important.
When the person spends
once, but not again,
actually we see a
30% to 40% drop-off--
I thinks 40 to 50
actually-- drop-off
between the first purchase
and second and third.
So if you think about the
spending behavior of somebody
who buys once but not
again, but continues
to spend time on
your game, they're
becoming more like
a non-buyer to you.
So we have special offers for
their first dollar conversion.
Also have something similar for
the special second and third
conversion later
down in the game.
Are you guys familiar with the
concept of price elasticity?
Anybody know what this is?
Awesome.
It's just a very fancy way of
saying different willingness
to pay.
So let me give you example.
What's your name?
Atkin, OK.
If I want to buy your shoes,
how much would you sell it for?
$50.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Eve.
MOONLIT: Would you
buy that for $50?
Would you buy it for $50?
Would you?
AUDIENCE: No.
MOONLIT: Anybody want
to by it for $40?
$30?
So here's the idea.
For the exact same
item, different people
have different
willingness to pay.
And that's why
somebody asked earlier,
do we need to test
different prices?
The answer is yes.
And what do we test for?
So on this graph, you can
see the negative correlation
between price and quantity.
You want to test
different price points,
such that the area under the
curve, or price times quantity,
is maximized.
And that's your revenue
maximizing point, price point.
But another question is,
when you AB test prices,
when players feel like,
oh, I got this for $5,
but he gets it for $3--
so here's a trick.
When you test
different price points,
also have different
in-game items.
So the price per item
is fixed, but you're
bundling different items
at different price points.
It's a way to gauge where a
user is more likely to take out
the wallet and spend,
even though they're buying
fundamentally different things.
Make sense?
So a lot of these
games have an IAP store
in the game, where you
service different points,
different prices, different
SKUs for different players.
So think about managing
this as managing
a real retail store,
like Whole Foods.
You want to keep it
new, keep it refreshed,
keep it fresh, for
users to come back,
build a habit of checking
it, see what's going on.
So this is one of actually my
previous company, Congregate,
game.
So what they did
is that they would
vary the items in the store
based on different things--
time-based, they're
different promotions,
based on time of the
year, time of the week.
Progression-based, sometimes
you offer different things
with people at different parts
of different parts of the game.
And also, they have
temporary promotions
and more permanent ones.
So really think about managing
it to keep it engaging.
It's almost like
a store in itself.
Now, the most
important question you
want to ask when you design
anything with a price tag on it
is, why would my
players buy this?
Are they buying it
out of frustration?
Or buying it because it
gives them more premium
experience, to give
them more delight?
And my vote is for the latter.
Anything with a price
tag on it should
be aimed to enhance the
player's in-game experience.
You also want to show them
why they want to buy it.
So it's not very clear
with the virtual goods
what's the purpose of that.
A lot of people have
encouraged users
to try out premium
currency or premium
item as part of the tutorial,
just to showcase the value--
again, the value of the
items you're selling.
Another one is, timing
is very important.
Think about why.
If you have item that
offers extended game played,
surface it when the game ends.
So timing the surfacing
with the player's need.
Next, I want to touch on some
quick, high-level lessons
about live ops.
You guys heard of live
ops, live operations?
To do it well, oftentimes
you do need a dedicated team,
or even one person, to run it.
But I want to share
some high-level insights
or learnings that can help
you think about increasing
engagement and
increasing value, again,
ultimately to increase your LTV.
So live ops has three
interrelated elements--
content, event, and sales.
And of the three,
content is king.
It powers both events and sales.
For events, there are two
types of things you can run.
The first one is called
the core game loops events,
where you have time-limited
goals and achievements
to encourage players to replay
part of the existing core
gameplay.
So for example,
for strategy games
is to redo the pass rates.
For RPG is to replay something.
And for puzzle games is
to increase the life,
so you can try
different levels again.
And if you have the ability
to dynamically introduce
piece of new content--
we call this the
dynamic content--
where you introduce
side missions,
additional new content
for the players to try,
but again with a
time-limited fashion.
The second idea about sales
is that it doesn't always
have to be about IAP
discounts, which often would
inflate your in-game economy.
So think about
running sales as a way
to bundle your existing
IAP options with something
extra in the item, in the SKU.
So for example,
for strategy games,
sometimes they throw
in a free builder
for a limited period of time
if you purchase certain IAP.
And for RPG and puzzle,
think about different ways
you can make the content
more interesting on top
of IAP discount.
Now, I'll share with
you a collection
of some of the most
common in-game designs.
Again, most of
these will probably
be very familiar to you.
But my goal is to give
you some new ideas
and think about different
ways to innovate.
Starter pack-- somebody
mentioned this earlier.
It's by far the
most effective way
to convert that first dollar.
A lot of games offer a bundle
of items at a huge discount, 40%
or more.
The goal is to increase
that very first buy.
Timing's very important too.
The first seven
days after install
is the golden period to
surface starter pack.
And as I mentioned earlier
about the second purchase,
think about using a second
purchase starter pack
if a player buys something
but stops buying,
but continues to stay with
your game for a longer
period of time.
Many developers also
make it time-limited
to showcase scarcity,
to encourage purchase,
again within the
first seven days.
Premium content.
David mentioned earlier that
premium content by itself
does not quite work.
But think about instead
of premium content as in
to pay to play the game, period,
about any pieces of content
in your game can have a
premium version of it--
premium clothes, premium
maps, premium powers.
So think about breaking out
different pieces of your game
and a premium level of that.
Social spending is when we
have higher willingness to pay,
where you're buying an item
as a gift to your friends,
not for yourself.
So this concept also applies
for mobile games as well.
Games with guilds
or social elements
sometimes let user purchase a
premium item that will actually
benefit their friends.
Competition is very important.
It's one of the drivers
why people will purchase.
Earlier, David mentioned that
when you have vanity items,
it's most effective in
the more PvP setting.
It's not just so
that you can showcase
your unique
personality and style,
but it also works really, really
well if these vanity items also
signal strength and skills.
So level 1 item will look
very different from level 100.
And for games with
competition as an element,
that signal, that social
proof, is very important
and can be a driver for
good monetization design.
Power-ups is a pretty
common one, most often seen
in casual games.
This is when players
are especially
stuck on a certain level.
Again, your goal is to help them
spend more time in your game
in a longer period of time.
So when they're stuck, the best
way to help them overcome that,
and power-up is a
way to help them
progress faster in the more
difficult-- or even earlier
in game.
Customization, as mentioned
earlier, most effective
in PvP games.
But even in games that's
not strictly social,
people do spend money when
they think about this,
have different ways of
representing their styles.
One of the very
popular genre right
now is interactive story games.
You can argue it's very much
a single player experience.
But when I'm faced the
choice to wear something
very plain or really customize
a character to showcase who
I am inside, that money becomes
not that big of a deal anymore.
Extended game play is another
way to think about monetizing.
This is very often used in
games that are time-limited
or it's a skill-based.
So this is also often
seen not just as IAP
but also as rewarded adds,
since it's a very quick way
to extend gameplay.
Game players have a little
bit extra to help push them
over that hurdle.
Some games also have this very
direct way to pay as a way
to shortcut leveling.
So instead of grinding for
months or weeks and month, day,
they can pay a
small amount instead
to speed up at a
very early stage.
I only recommend this if
you have a lot of content
already out for the game.
So think about strategy
game or some PvP games
where everybody's up here.
I just joined the game.
I want to catch up to them.
That is one way to do that.
But if you don't have
a lot of content,
and if you have a premium
option to help player
fast forward the game, they
might run out of content.
And they might churn.
So really think about balance
the time and the value element
of your game design.
Now, the next two designs,
monetization designs,
are not strictly
in-app purchases.
But it's a trend that we've seen
picked up by game developers
from all around the world.
The first one is
designing subscription
as a way to engage the
high value players.
So think of subscription,
not as a content bundle,
but as a VIP program, like
the airline mileage program.
It's used to really amplify
the player's time and value
and especially IAP spending.
We call these the
multiplier for IAP.
So this is a game called
Legendary Game of Heroes
by NETWORK.
They have a VIP program
that's ever-growing.
And everything you
do in game gives you
VIP points, whether it is
to complete a challenge
or purchase some IAP items.
And as you accumulate
more points,
you also unlock more benefits.
And you have to be
a VIP subscriber
to activate these benefits.
They've seen
incredible retention.
So actually this is true
for many other mobile game
developers who have in-game
subscriptions implemented.
The often reported a higher
retention, also higher LTV.
Again, remember, more time
spent and longer period of time
leads to higher LTV.
The second one is rewarded ads.
For this one, the
trick here is to think
about how to optimize it, how to
incorporate in your game design
so it's more effective.
So the framework I like to use
have four different elements.
The first one is placement.
Where do you place it?
The recommendation
from Congregate
is that the rewarded ads should
be core to your game play.
The reward itself
should be meaningful,
but not competing
directly with IAP.
The second one is targeting.
Who can see it?
And the answer is that
everybody should have access
to rewarded ads.
But the recommendation
is that user
should initiate the experience.
But again, you should test this
out, as David said earlier.
There is no one right
answer for all the games.
The third one is cadence.
How often should the
user watch rewarded ads?
Congregate tested
many things and found
that six to eight ads per
viewer per day maximizes return.
And the last one is measurement.
How do you know your rewarded
ad is working as intended?
So they cohort their user base
based on these two metrics,
ad viewership and frequency.
Who's watching it?
And how often are
they watching it?
Track your core metrics--
the retention, engagement,
buyer conversion metrics
I mentioned earlier--
by these two cohorts.
And you want to see if
they behave differently
if they watch too many
ads or no ads at all.
Next, I'll share some tips about
going global with Google Play.
We know when you launch your
game with us your game is
by default available--
if you make so--
all over the world.
And different players, besides
different price points,
also have their
preferred way of payment.
Credit cards here, WeChat
in different places, PayPal.
But for Google Play, we
try to find different ways
to let users pay with
the form of payment
where they're most comfortable.
So these are some
of the latest stats
on where things are available
and how many countries they're
available in.
So we take care of
the billing part,
so you can focus
on making the game.
Now, when you launch
your game, you
have the store listing page.
It is the very first thing
that players will see
when they come into your game.
So making sure that your store
listing page is appealing,
is relevant culturally, and it's
relevant in the local language
is very, very important.
So here are some tips about how
to manage your storefront so
that when a user
comes in, they're more
likely to install the game.
I'm not going to go
through each of these.
You can read through it.
But what I do
suggest is that you
use the store listing
experiments, free and available
in the Google Play Console, to
really test what kind of icons
have the highest conversion,
what kind of screenshots,
what kind of short description
and long description.
You might be surprised
by what you find.
Remember this
graph from earlier?
Price elasticity is also true.
It varies country
by country as well.
So what that means is
for many countries,
even $1 is a little
too bit too much.
So we have this option
for sub-dollar pricing
in many, many emerging markets.
The exchange rate here
is a little outdated.
But the point here is that
exchange rates fluctuate.
People's willingness
to pay fluctuates.
So it's a lot of work
for you to pay attention
to these fluctuations and
think about different ways
and different price points.
So Google Play Console
has a pricing template
that you can use.
It will automatically
update these for you.
But when you think about
pricing emerging markets,
consider the lowest
point of SKU,
such that these players who
can't afford higher price item
can still take out their
wallet and purchase your items.
Here's a case study from a
Vietnamese developer called
Divmob.
When they launched sub-dollar
pricing in their game,
they were able to triple--
triple their buyers and triple
the number of transactions.
So really think about
meeting your players
where their
willingness to pay is.
The very last thing is it's not
only about the absolute price
points, but also how the
price looks matters, too,
when it comes to conversion.
A lot of things in America,
things end in $0.99.
It's not true in Asia, not true
in China, not true in Korea,
not true in Japan.
So when you think about prices,
just doing the pure conversion
of the exchange rate might
make the end price look really
weird for the local user.
So not just convert
your prices, but think
about localizing, culturalizing
your prices as well.
One takeaway from my talk--
running a game as a service--
the most important
thing is to think
about how to increase
your player's lifetime
value and the two factors
that mostly affect
your total LTV,
time and the value,
which converts to
engagement and value.
For engagement, think
about retention.
Think about session
frequency, session time.
Think about stickiness factor.
And for value, think about
the first dollar conversion
and second buyer conversion.
All right.
Thank you so much.